In the context of the
problem of estimating
the unknown bias of a coin, we
encountered this distribution,
which is known as a
Beta distribution.
It's a probability density
for a random variable, Theta,
that takes values in the
interval from 0 to 1.
So this formula is valid
for thetas in this range.
And k here is a
non-negative integer.
Now, this coefficient
here, d(n,k),
is a normalizing constant,
which is needed so that this is
a legitimate PDF, that
it integrates to 1.
And so in particular,
d needs to be
equal to the integral of what
we have in the numerator.
This is the choice that makes
this whole expression integrate
to 1.
And this integral is
calculated and can
be found to be equal to
this particular expression.
How do we derive
this expression?
One way is to carry out a
long exercise in calculus.
We have this integral here.
You might either expand it
and then integrate and collect
terms, or you could try to
demonstrate this equality
by applying
integration by parts.
But this is complicated.
Is there some simple way
of arguing and deriving
this expression?
We will see that there is a very
simple probabilistic argument
for deriving this equality.
What we will actually derive
is this same equality,
but in slightly
different notation.
Instead of k, we will use alpha.
Instead of n minus
k, we will use beta.
So here we have alpha
factorial times beta factorial.
In the denominator,
we have the sum
of these two
coefficients plus 1,
so this corresponds to alpha
plus beta plus 1 factorial.
This is what we
want to demonstrate.
What we will do will be to
consider the following setting.
We start with alpha
plus beta plus 1,
that many independent
random variables that
are uniform on
the unit interval,
and we will consider
the following event
and its probability.
This is the probability
that these random variables
happen to be ordered in
some particular order.
Let us call this event A, so
this is the probability of A.
Now, this probability is
not hard to calculate.
We have alpha plus beta plus 1
random variables-- independent,
identically distributed.
By symmetry, any
particular way of ordering
these random variables
is equally likely.
How many ways are there
to order alpha plus beta
plus 1 random variables?
It's the factorial of
the number of items
that we're trying to order.
We're talking about
the probability
of a particular permutation,
so this probability
is equal to 1 over the
number of permutations
of alpha plus beta
plus 1 objects.
So this is one expression for
the probability of this event
A.
Now, we're going to
calculate this probability
in a different way.
What we will do is we're going
to apply the total probability
theorem.
We're going to
condition on Z. We're
going to calculate the
conditional probability of A
given that Z takes
a specific value,
and then weigh those
probabilities according
to the probability density
of the random variable Z.
So this is just the
total probability theorem
applied to this
particular context.
And now to make progress,
what we will need to do
is to find this
conditional probability.
We fix a constant little theta,
and we want the probability
that this event happens.
What is this event?
It is the event that all of the
X's fall inside this interval,
all the Y's fall
inside this interval,
and furthermore, the X's are
sorted and the Y's are sorted.
So let us write this out.
It's the probability that
all of the X's happen
to be less than
theta, all the Y's
happen to be bigger than
theta, and also, not just that,
but the X's are sorted,
and furthermore, the Y's
are sorted as well.
Clearly, if I give
you the value of theta
so that Z is equal to theta,
for this event to happen,
we must have all these
events here happen as well.
So now, let us try to calculate
the probability of this event.
We're going to use the
multiplication rule.
First, take the
probability of this event
and then the conditional
probability of that event.
The X's and the Y's
are independent,
so we can take the probability
of this event and then multiply
with the probability of this
event involving the Y's.
How about the probability
of this event,
that all of the X's
are less than theta?
Since the X's are
independent, this
is going to be equal
to the probability
that X1 is less than theta.
What is this probability?
Since X1 is uniform on the unit
interval and this is theta,
the probability of
falling in this interval
is equal to theta.
Times the probability that
X2 is less than theta.
This probability is,
again, theta and so on.
We have alpha many
terms of that kind,
so this probability that all
of these random variables
are less theta is equal to
theta to the power of alpha.
Similarly, about the Y's.
For any particular
Y, the probability
that it falls in
this interval is
equal to the length of
this interval, which
is 1 minus theta.
This is the probability
for each one of the Y's.
There's beta many Y's.
The Y's are independent.
So the probability that all
of them fall in this interval
is going to be this number
to the power of beta.
So suppose that I told
you that all the X's are
less than theta,
and then I ask you,
given this information,
what is the probability
that the X's that
you got are arranged
in this particular order?
Now, because of the complete
symmetry of the problem,
even if I told you that all the
X's fall inside this interval,
any order of the X's
is equally likely.
So the probability of
this particular order
is going to be 1 over the
number of possible orderings.
How many ways are there that
alpha items can be ordered?
There are alpha factorial
possible orderings,
so the probability that I
obtain one particular ordering
is 1 over alpha factorial.
And similarly, if I tell
you that the Y's all
fell in this
interval by symmetry,
the probability of
a particular order
is going to be 1 over
the [number of possible]
orders, which is beta factorial.
All right.
So we have this
conditional probability,
and now we can go back to
this formula and substitute,
and what we obtain is the
integral of this expression,
theta to the alpha, 1 minus
theta [to the] beta, 1
over alpha factorial times
1 over beta factorial.
Then we have the density of
Z, but since Z is uniform,
the density is equal to 1.
And then we have a
factor of d theta.
So what have we achieved?
We calculated the
probability of the event A
in two different ways, and we
got two seemingly different
answers.
But these two answers
have to agree.
Therefore, this expression
is equal to that expression.
And now if you take this factor,
1 over alpha factorial times 1
over beta factorial, and
send it to the other side
of the equation, what we
obtain is exactly the formula
that we wished to derive.
This example is an
instance of the following.
There are certain
formulas in mathematics
that are somewhat
complicated to derive,
and their derivations
using, for example,
calculus are quite unintuitive.
But once you interpret
the various terms that
appear in such a relation
in a probabilistic way,
you can sometimes find very easy
derivations and explanations
why such a formula
has to be true.